les italiens auraient mme les français
commencent à y penser faudra-t-il un
jour effet c'est la dette liée aux
qu'ovide alimenté par des plans de
relance pharaonique pour faire face à la
pandémie
l'endettement public explose à travers
l'europe en france on approche des 120 %
de dette par rapport au pib
alors peut-on remettre les compteurs à
zéro pour mieux repartir pour l'heure
bercy et la bce s'y refuse mais pour
combien de temps on voit ça tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
bonsoir avec cette question de
l'aggravation de la dette publique est
ce que c'est si urgent pour qu'elle
impose à ce point dans saint paul à ce
point justement dans le débat public
alors oui il y a un problème de dette
publique mais il est aussi vrai que l'on
instrumentalise politiquement la dette
publique alors il est évident que la
crise sanitaire et la crise économique
qu'elle engendre ont provoqué dans la
plupart des pays une très forte
augmentation de la dette publique
mais cette dette certains en flandre
épouvantail
ainsi quand olivier dussopt le ministre
des comptes publics ou bruno le maire le
ministre des finances martèle que cette
dette doit être remboursé qu'elle sera
remboursé évidemment ils prennent une
position qui est plus politique
qu'économique car en réalité il ya de
nombreuses manières de gérer sa tête
alors rappelons tout de suite que en
1946 après la guerre la dette en
pourcentage du pib est bien elle était
bien au delà des 120 % actuels et
pourtant
en 1960 elle était revenue à 35% du pib
il faut donc c'est celle de faire peur
et de se faire peur avec cette dette
publique et tous s'en servir comme d'un
prétexte ou d'un levier pour des
politiques d'austérité
alors en quoi cet accroissement de la
dette est il sans précédent alors oui il
est clair que la crise sanitaire a
provoqué une très forte montée de la
dette publique dans tous les grands pays
quel qu'ait été leur situation
financière avant 2020 la crise in la
crise sanitaire et l'effondrement
économique elle a engendré on
conduit à une très forte envolée de la
dette publique
les chiffres du fmi que l'on voit sur le
graphique qui résultent destinations qui
ont été faits il faut le souligner avant
la deuxième vague montrent que la dette
devrait connaître un pic à la fin de
l'année si on inclut les effets de la
deuxième vague
il est probable que le pic sera décalée
sur 2021 mais remarquons aussi que cette
envolée n'est pour l'instant pas aussi
forte que celle résultant de la crise
financière de 2008 et remarquons enfin
que le problème sera très sérieux en
italie et il n'est donc pas du tout
étonnant que le débat sur l'annulation
de la dette et commencer là bas mais il
apparaît aussi que des problèmes
similaires se feront sentir en france en
belgique en espagne et au portugal
alors jacques peut-on mesurer la dette
engendrée par l'épidémie du cog vide
oui on peut l'estimer même s'il est
assez difficile de le faire avec
précision l'encore si on prend les
estimations qui ont été fournies par le
fonds monétaire international pour 2020
et 2021
on peut en avoir une image mais une
image à minima parce que je me rappelle
ces estimations
elles datent d'avant la deuxième vague
alors qu'est ce qu'on constate dans on
constate effectivement que certains pays
se sont fortement endettés et si l'on
prend justement les six pays qui sont
sur ce graphique et bien on voit que ils
ont accumulé a aussi à peu près 13 150
milliards de dette en deux ans peut-être
un peu plus même bon et que l'union
européenne ou plus exactement la zone
euro accumulera elle environ 2000
milliards de dettes alors pourquoi
parler d'annulation de la dette est la
raison en est simple
de nombreux économistes mais aussi des
des hommes politiques comme arnaud
montebourg craignent que cette dette ou
plus exactement que ce surcroît de dette
engendrée par la crise sanitaire
n'empêche les pays de la zone euro de
redémarrer économiquement
le problème n'est pas nouveau 1 lors de
la crise financière de 2008 la fameuse
crise des subprimes la dette avait aussi
explosé la volonté de certains
gouvernements de rythme
i la dette dans les années qui ont suivi
immédiatement ce cri avait fortement
limiter la croissance
cela a été le cas en france avec la
politique menée par le gouvernement
fillon alors f1 risque réel observé
stéphanie quand on voit que l'on reparle
ainsi de la réforme des retraites
bruno le maire en a parlé au tout
récemment justement à cause de la dette
cody ai dit effectivement on peut le
craindre
alors comment faire pour annuler cette
fameuse dette
il y a plusieurs solutions tout d'abord
la banque centrale européenne peut tout
simplement décidé d'acheter la dette
directement aux états alors que pour
l'instant elle ne peut pas le faire du
moins en théorie et conserver la dette
qu'elle a achetés pendant une longue
période ils ont 2 50 à 75 ans alors mais
christine lagarde pour la bce s'y est
refusé non oui effectivement
effectivement c'est fini elle a déclaré
que cela était impensable à plusieurs
reprises et pourtant il faut savoir que
christine lagarde fait tout ce qui est
en son possible pour maintenir les taux
d'intérêt au plus bas
alors est ce que ce n'est pas un peu
contradictoire j'assure bien sûr on voit
bien que christine lagarde est d'un côté
limitée dans son action par les pays qui
tiennent à une forme d'austérité que ce
soit la finlande l'autriche les pays acp
et surtout à l'allemagne mais que d'un
autre côté elle fait tout ce qu'elle
peut pour que les pays puissent trouver
les liquidités nécessaires
alors y at il d'autres solutions oui
naturellement naturellement c'est à dire
les pays de la zone euro par exemple
pourrait décider à l'unanimité de par
exemple d'annuler une partie de leurs
dettes redisons 20%
on appelle ça dans l'argot des banquiers
un arc qui nous coupe de cheveux cela
d'ailleurs il faut le dire c'est déjà
pratiqué pour la grèce mais il faudrait
d'une part l'unanimité des pays de la
zone euro et surtout que ce fameux
haircut ne soient pas accompagnés de
clauses contraignantes comme cela a été
le cas pour la grèce en particulier
autrement dit ça reste une option qui
est peu probable
alors on parle aussi de transformer la
dette en dettes perpétuelles
effectivement effectivement et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire que l'état
annonce qu'il ne paiera pas le capital
mais qu'il s'engage à payer les intérêts
sur une très longue période
de fait la grande bretagne vient de
racheter il ya quelques mois la dette
perpétuelle qu'elle avait émise pour
financer les guerres napoléoniennes donc
voyez où tout début du 19e siècle
là encore faut signaler qu'il faudrait
un accord de l'ensemble de la zone euro
pour éviter justement que les taux
d'intérêt ne soit trop élevé alors en
conclusion jacques avec toutes ses
limites il n'y a pas franchement de
solution c'est fini c'est là où l'on
mesure effectivement le problème qui est
posé par la rigidité des institutions
européennes et en particulier de la zone
euro des solutions sont tous les petits
n'est d'ailleurs pas la même solution
soit adaptée à chaque pays mais le plus
simple reste quand même que la banque
centrale puisse racheter directement des
trésors sur une longue période ont deux
trois peut être quatre années or la
banque centrale européenne ne veut pas
du fait de l'existence de l'euro les
banques centrales nationales elles ne le
peuvent pas et donc il est à craindre
que la question de la dette qui pour
l'instant relativement indolore puisque
les taux d'intérêt sont très bas
bien que cette question de la dette
empoisonne le débat public et
contraignent dramatiquement les
politiques publiques dans un certain
avenir et bien jacques merci pour cet
éclairage et à la semaine prochaine